so who you texting tonight on the red
carpet me phone out right there he
hiding it back immediately no no no no I
was playing Words With Friends oh no no
no no I was playing solitaire who you
texting right now yeah who are you
texting
I need my phones over there but I did
just takes Taylor Swift and Jamie King
we have like a group text and extend
them will be like selfies from all
angles I was like this is what's
happening right now they responded they
did respond they said very sweet things
I don't know
I can't imagine Taylor Swift is that
sweet Val you know I believe you I
believe you have you been texting
anybody else on this red carpet today
just my dear friend Robert Downey jr.
and my close personal pal Steven
Spielberg um oh I sent an audio missing
I can't wait to see you girl
okay 23 girl okay I take Laura she
didn't get back to me Laura bond is not
just a fun girl Michael's not working
what happened
there's so many people here my signals
down great what are some of the texts
you've been sending to these these
bigwigs
um which [ __ ] do you have your eye on
whoo-hoo gonna hit it first I probably
just texting like her something
something to you like where are you yeah
are you here are you nearby the security
made me move down to the end of the
carpet I can't escape and the way
background background and has anyone
seen my insults oh you're in so take it
away
those are my insults
is all mad [ __ ] all day it's seized
nuts all right hey thanks for stopping
by with this and if you know if you do
feel like texting anybody she would
happily take your number I'll take your
number you know you'll have to run that
by my p.m. I'll take oh okay what if I
took his number
I'm Way less threatening